Hey okay don't hurt nobody
hey that's a great skip thank you
how do we bring that back you should I'm
okay with that I'm all retired of like
dabbing but I liked it's perfect oh my
god we throw this out in idiot
this isn't original G show cocktail
slash lounge ottoman it's priceless
really it's Brit $75 okay not including
shipping well we gotta get it this is
perfect I can see me writing my very
first novel on this baby
hey I could see me now look AC me and
the mirror across the sheet you see what
up Playboy
alright come on Bob bring that
I lost that dog immediately how many
days did you have him one oh you should
have told me enrietto
you should have told me you should have
told me Henrietta
oh you're done done in now Henrietta no
wait you shouldn't have told me
Henrietta Oh Linus Henrietta Henrietta
why you want me to call Arrieta for you
baby because I'll call the method up but
I am prepared for one of three auditions
that I have today oh excuse me
congratulations mr. magic over here what
is that this original G gel cocktail
slash lounge ottoman was bestowed upon
us by faith yes we found it across the
street would you want street wear into
this house come on mo it's nice things
probably riddled with needles there were
only two needles in it
stop mo he's kidding he's playing he's
just kidding you know what I can't deal
with this right now I have to get ready
hey mo do you have Henrietta's number in
there are you yeah I'm sorry I couldn't
hear you cuz I'm too busy making strides
towards my dream what are you two doing
we're gonna be setting up the Ottoman
you're gonna set up date we will
no ma this is a feature film no no I did
student films in college yeah this is
just the audition my manager
no you said I have a really good shot at
this one so yeah hey ma I'm gonna call
you right back all right
hi oh my back into wine
oh no no yeah I'm not here to be an
extra oh sorry
hey oh no I'm here to audition for the
role of uh Lucas Oh you and everyone
else back to going Sally
great so sorry I was stupid
hey yeah see I have another audition at
3:00 calling me you have another
audition get right on accommodating you
for that oh hello show business we got a
guy he's coming in for an audition okay
we're gonna bring him yeah I think
they're all right back of the line okay
gonna be in the back
happiness is shoot Rock Paper Scissors
shoot
okay one more time one more kiss is it
okay Rock Paper Scissors shoot
okay so obviously we're both gonna keep
choosing paper how about I just go first
um no how about I use it first all right
well let me just throw something out
there how about I use the out early
first idea and I'm spitballing here walk
with me I'm gonna go you I'll use it
first mm-hmm you could use it after mmm
allow me to share with you a tale from
my past okay
when I was a young child my grandmother
who is now dead said to me my love first
is the worst and I remember that so
vividly and I can hear it in my head you
know
it's alright I remember god I never got
it went and I want to bear that burden
Paul I don't want that on you I don't
want you to have that kind of negative
energy I do it for you Paul do it for
you
hey if I made cookies would you have
some yeah okay so I'm thinking how about
I make maple bacon brown sugar cookies
right mm-hmm sounds good do you think I
had too much sugar I don't want to
diabetes
you
hi how you guys doing
did you sleep your name for the camera
please yeah sure uh-huh mmm hi I'm
watching me to stop you there uh we need
to fix this lighting Carl do you have it
light we got a light in for him we have
any extra lights we can bring in we get
a light can we get it like a like two or
two three lights can we get some lights
for this hey Paul
sup girl hey um so I have some some
spider bites and and and I think that
they may or may not have come from thee
from the Ottoman from Jill hello
spiders are everywhere in LA you
probably got one from outside silly I'll
tell you what I'll take my turn with the
Ottoman and if I get bit we'll cross
that bridge when we get there all right
okay just just be careful Paul all right
spider bites can be really dangerous
well danger is my middle name
okay joke it it's Philip mom now you
schedule these two clothes together man
no I'm at the third one now I didn't go
to the second one I didn't go to the
second one cuz I was not the first one
for three hours when I finally got in
the room it took 15 minutes to set up a
light because nobody's prepared they're
like a black man in America excuse me
I'm sorry to interrupt I don't have your
audition fee of $60 uh audition fee $60
yes one second please
huh I don't disagree come on man hello
hello hey Paul
huh gee Joe hey what time we got any
beer yeah but no what's wrong
Wow Wow what oh wow cigarette
I think I had an allergic reaction to
mice and Joe yeah Paul those are spider
bites No
then where could you possibly God spider
bites please tell me it's from this
upholstered gutter trash you two
insisted on bringing in here I swear to
god man get rid of that thing I'm
serious
mean I think it's cute
hey Paul hey hey hey don't move too like
two seconds
okay Mike whatever you do just don't
move okay how the hell is that
you said don't move I trusted your nose
you cheese that's why my face okay yeah
oh that's not good no I'm I uh I don't
think I got any of them today Wow
oh no you'll get something so yeah bye
that's out that's real sweet if you
change your mind the rec center back
home is still looking for acting coaches
you can save your money and then move
back out mom
I'm not changing my mind
Thanks
I just hope she knows how much I loved
her oh gee Joe uh-huh she knows Paul she
knows
thanks very much so it's like whenever I
told you to follow your dreams no one
tells you how fast they running away
from see you rehearsing again
mm-hm sounds like it but whatever it is
I hope he gets the role be good for him
every story you read every every
biography it's all totally for my point
of success all right guess it oh my
biography is about people who didn't
make it I'm not complaining
complaining is not gonna help me pay my
mom back
I'll give me the life that I'm trying to
live Plus complaints for losers and I'm
from Philly man on losing anything
you know what I'm just gonna keep
working keep believing and we gonna make
it I truly believe it we're gonna make
you know guys I'm really sorry about
you